okay we're ready when you are chair okay
okay thank you can i welcome everybody
to the licensing subcommittee for
tuesday the third of may
um the attendances are being recorded
um
now we have
we just have one item item two which is
the application for the grant of a full
variation
to a premises license under section 33
the licensing act 2003
at kennedy's
30-32 greenwood street ground floor
altering them
okay now do we have the the applicant
here
we're the applicant but we have got a
solicitor richard williams is he not on
i'm here rebecca hi
i'm just making sure i couldn't see you
i'm in that line
right and you'll be representing mr
williams will you uh that's right chair
yes i'm just listen to representing
kennedy's
right and do we have um
do we have an officer from the
environmental health
are you hi yeah good evening council
gentlemen it's richard [ __ ] here from
environmental protection mr pollock okay
thank you
okay i'm councillor german i'll be
chairing the hearing and with me i've
got councillors but and thomas
we have offices from the legal licensing
and governance sections
so what what i'll do first is i'll run
through the procedure for the meeting
so that everybody's clear what's going
to happen
so first i will ask the licensing
officer to out there outline the
application
i will then ask the applicant and or
their representative to address the
subcommittee and call any witnesses
the applicant and each of their
witnesses may then be questioned by
members of the subcommittee officers and
any other party making representation
the party making representation you'll
be referred to as the representator
and or the representative will then be
given an opportunity to address the
subcommittee
and call any witnesses
the representative and any of their any
of their witnesses may then be
questioned by members of the
subcommittee officers and any other
party making representation
we just have uh one represent
representer which is from environmental
health and that's mr pollock who's just
identified himself
um so after this i'll request all
parties involved to summarize
the representative excuse me
will be given two minutes to summarise
followed by the applicant who will also
be given two minutes to summarise
we will then go into recess where the
subcommittee will consider their
decision and i will then announce the
determination of the application
and the reasons for the determination
this this will be confirmed in writing
within five days of the hearing
so is everybody clear about the process
yes
okay
chad before you start could i just ask
please there's been some fairly
significant modifications to this
application and withdrawal of various
elements of it which i know uh the
council officers have i just think it
might short circuit things if
um you could just confirm that you have
that uh that document
uh yeah the document you sent today
that's right yes thank you chair yeah
that's fine it's just that i wouldn't
want you to run through the entirety of
the variation and then for me to tell
you the majority of it's been withdrawn
no no no no we say yeah so
the withdrawals are in red and the
things we have to consider are in yellow
that's right yes thank you
to do i think to do mainly to do with
the outside area i think it's a name
correct contentious issue
okay um with that i'll ask the licensing
officer if if they'll um if they'll
outline the application please for the
for the hearing
um
a premises license is required in
respect of any premises where it is
intended to conduct one or more of the
four licensing
objectives those being the sale of
alcohol the supply of alcohol
regulated entertainment
and or the provision of late night
refreshment
this application was submitted by
marilyn gale solicitor for and on behalf
of kennedy hospitality limited
in respect of canada's
32 greenwood street ground floor ultra
income
wa14 1rz
the licensing authority is satisfied
that the application has been made
properly
and our procedures correctly followed
the applicant has applied to extend the
opening hours and sales alcohol to add
non-stop timings for sale of alcohol and
recorded music
additionally they have applied to vary
three conditions and an additional
condition and to vary the plan
specifically
to extend the licensable activities sale
of alcohol on and off until 2 a.m friday
to saturday this includes christmas eve
new year's eve
st patrick's day
and sunday's preceding bank holidays
so i've recorded music on christmas eve
new year's eve st patrick's day and
sunday's preceding bank holidays uh
until 1am
to extend the opening hours to 2 a.m
um
to vary the layout plan to include the
rear kiosk within the license area
to amend the wording of conditions 11 17
and 19 of the current license and to add
a condition seizing the sale of alcohol
at the kiosk after 9 pm
consultation period it was agreed with
the police that the extension of the
opening hours
and the
sale of alcohol on and off um
to remain existing
and that conditions 11 and 17 were to
remain as existing attached appendix e
along with additional documents from
environmental health
which has been passed to the members
the only part of the variation which is
contested and should be determined is
the amended condition 19.
this application has been referred to
the licensing subcommittee because
during the consultation period a
representation was received against the
grant of variation from environmental
health on the grounds of public nuisance
a copy of the representation is attached
at appendix d1 to the report
the subcommittee is asked to consider
the application and the representations
of all parties
and make its decision
in arriving at its decision the
subcommittee must also have regard to
relevant provisions of national guidance
and its own statement of licensing
policy
the reasons should be given for any
departure
the options open to the subcommittee are
to grant the application in full and on
the terms and conditions contained
within the application to include any
applicable mandatory conditions
to grant the application but modified to
such an extent as considered appropriate
to satisfy any relevant representations
and promote the licensing objectives
or to reject the application
that is the end of my summary of the
application unless the submit committee
have any questions for me at the stage
thank you miss pickup does anybody have
any questions for the licensing officer
at this stage no thank you chair
can i just ask you miss miss pickup i'm
not expecting the answer right away
um you may have to up to uh dig dig it
out but the the
the i believe the kennedys is in between
two other bars one which is next door
uh
or next door but one which is riddles
cocktail bar that's next door not me you
did next door
and one further down the road on the
other side the belgian uh belgium bar
would you be able to
dig out what the timings are for the
terminal hour for the outside area
of course yeah i'm not expecting you
have the answer right away
i think that would be helpful i think
that chair if i could just say the uh
con club will also be one i'll make
reference to on greenwood street which
is a similar
uh which is just slightly further away
the reason being obviously we you know
we'll point to consistency between
licensed premises on the same street i
have to say it is incredibly difficult
with no access online to the council's
licensing register anymore to be able to
get this information or else i would
have provided it as part of the
um
presentation to the committee
yeah thank you i know you i know you
raised that in your
written submission
and i think the environmental health
officer said it was slightly different
because it was in a separate
block and there was no sort of upstairs
residential properties but i mean it's
all relevant so um
if you can look at that as well
the the terminal out of the outside area
that would be helpful
um
okay
then
if you'd like to mr williams if you'd
like to uh
speak to your application or your
clients application
yes certainly uh chair and uh committee
members um
i have here with me uh rebecca watts and
adam richardson if you wish to hear
anything operationally for them but if i
can just first of all apologize for the
complexity of this application i
appreciate it is complex the decision we
took originally was to extend the hours
and to look at the external area but for
historical reasons
changes were needed to some of the
conditions on the license as a tidying
up exercise
and therefore what we're now left with
is actually a very modest
variation i'll explain the reason for
that um and i'll be quite honest with
you that the operator was looking to
extend the licensing hours till two
o'clock as well as other variations
the police quite rightly were concerned
about those an extension until two
o'clock in the morning and sought a
condition requiring a door supervisor
now just from a practical perspective
they have a license at the moment as
you'll appreciate with one o'clock times
on it without any door supervisor
conditions
uh they can't go backwards
from those hours that are already uh
imposed on the license making a
variation so you can't be any worse off
after a variation and having discussed
the um variation with the police on a
very sensible basis um we put to the
police that there are simply not enough
door supervisors to go around at the
moment which will mean to say that if
your door supervisor doesn't turn up you
would actually have to close the
premises say from nine o'clock at night
and therefore it was agreed between all
the parties um that they would stand as
they are now with their licensing hours
the only change to that is there are
minor modifications if you've seen these
non-standard timings for alcohol and
recorded music so adding on uh boxing
day and other days
um until one o'clock now we spoke to the
police this morning they were happy with
that without there being an sia
condition so i would say the first two
elements of this application for
variation of the non-standard timings
are not contentious
they're not opposed by gmp and as i
understand it environmental health don't
have any
objections to that element so i think
it's only the
outside area that we need to address and
that's the reason for this hearing now
if you know greenwood street and you
know kennedy's and you've probably been
able to see from i think appendix b2 if
you don't
that we're talking about a very small
external area here there are two benches
and i've counted about 12 chairs that go
outside into this small area so it's not
a question of being potential for
hundreds of people to sit outside
in the evening it's all on the front on
greenwood street
and you're absolutely right chad that
the
uh to the right hand side i think i'm
saying is right is riddles which is a a
bar the left hand side is the belgian
bar and a little bit further across from
the market down greenwood street is the
con club
and we would make the point to the
councillors that
none of those
premises as far as we're aware and as i
say it's difficult to get this
information but certainly i have the
information for the con club
have restrictions on the use of their
external area so that in actual fact
people could sit on greenwood street at
the front of the con club until midnight
when its license ends and they wouldn't
have to be moved on whereas as things
stand on the premises license we
currently have a restriction of 10
o'clock sunday to thursday and 11
o'clock fridays and saturdays and on
those special days
now the application as it stands which i
understand is opposed by environmental
health
is to add one hour onto the use of the
external area sunday to thursday
and to add one hour on fridays saturdays
and those special days
will be i'm not sure there's gonna be
that many people sitting outside on
christmas eve or boxing day but that's
part of the application
so that people would be permitted to sit
outside uh until midnight and i'm going
to let
the premises explain to you
in a short while why that why that
application is made but in essence the
outside area is used as a drinking area
has been used particularly during kobit
as a
drinking area after these times drinks
and food can't be taken out but they
simply get into dispute with people who
are saying well i can
have a drink here until one o'clock in
the morning but you're asking me to
come back in at 11 o'clock so two hours
before
the terminal hour and this can lead to
disputes on the door now
we're not aware of any noise complaints
from greenwood street where we are aware
there are residential premises above uh
some of the licensed premises on
greenwood street we're not aware of any
noise complaints we're not aware of any
noise issues with the use of this
external area
and simply therefore the request is to
extend the use of the area up to a
terminal hour of midnight on fridays and
saturdays and those special days now my
understanding is environmental health
are happy with 11 o'clock as a cap to
use of the external area but the
midnight they disagree with because they
believe that will lead to public
um nuisance
um now our point as i say would be that
we see consistency so whether it's
riddles whether it's the belgian bar or
whether it's the con club that if those
premises don't have similar restrictions
so um
you know what's good for them is good
for us so if
they are allowed to trade until midnight
with people outside um that we should be
as well and rebecca i think you've got a
case in point over this bank holiday
weekend where other premises on
greenwood street were allowing people to
sit outside until midnight yet to comply
with your license condition
you had to bring people in at 11. do you
want to just explain the reason behind
this application
okay then so
i'll give this weekend as an example but
it happens quite often the week at
weekends is that
come 10 o'clock or 11 o'clock mid 11
o'clock weekends we have to go out and
tell people to come in we do it in
advance because we want to get everyone
in by 11.
um although we don't get hassles people
just don't understand why people one
side of us on the other side of us and
the rest of the street are still sitting
out and they think we're making it up so
i just say it's a licensing thing we
can't serve out here and then some
people leave us and commercially lose we
lose money go down the road or go to
somewhere else because they want to stay
sitting outside so we lose customers
from it because they go to next door
even next door to us so they get a drink
going next door um
and obviously further down the road
so it's commercially unfair to start
with so they're allowed sir more people
outside
customers aren't particularly happy with
us because i think we're making it up
um and um
other places down because i don't
understand that next door but one to us
is a flat above but belgium bar's got a
flat above the back of conclude they've
got a big external area which is on the
first floor and that is directly next to
someone's flat
so and on um this weekend about half 11
they had like a big dj there blaring out
down the back right next to someone's
house and we were had all our windows
shut we had everyone inside and we were
really really quiet and obviously
they're allowed to do that it just
doesn't seem very commercially fair and
just
fair on basic licensing rules really
that the rest of the streets allowed it
and we're not
and rebecca can you just tell me you've
got you have got a condition on your
license which will remain they're saying
after that time it could be used for
smoking but no food and drink are taken
into that
external area so how do how does that
work at the cl at the closing time what
do you do
we have to um well at the closing time
at the outside we have to have a
permanent member of staff in the week
whatever
permanently standing there because
people go with their drinks to go
outside so we have to tell them to keep
their drinks in they can go and smoke
but keep their drinks in so it's also
costly on the aspect that we have to
have extra staffing just to manage that
outside space
okay but if you were granted a midnight
restriction on fridays and saturdays and
those
special days then you would manage that
to ensure that people weren't sitting
out there drinking yeah most of our
clients between 12 and 1 is just what's
left in there we don't generally have
lots of people coming left it but back
in and out and everything like that and
it's kind of like a wind down really
from 12 to 1 anyway
okay and how many people are we talking
about maximum capacity outside well you
you're slightly wrong so outside we've
got probably about 40 i thought
40. okay
there's two benches and more than two
benches there's five five benches five
benches okay okay i couldn't see from
appendix i think it's b1 or b2 about how
many people
are out there and is it cordoned off
this air this external area is the same
as everyone else um
yeah so it's all buried off with barrels
and barriers okay and other than people
do you have any music or anything else
outside no we we shut our windows at 11
o'clock because that's the stipulate of
the thing so we've got like big bifold
windows but they get shot at 11 anyway
okay so the only um disturbance that
could be is people sitting outside
uh having a drink yeah the same as
everywhere else yeah and uh so i was
going to say and so how does does that
differ from the belgian bar or the con
club or are they doing the same thing no
everybody when we're getting people in
that's what the customers don't
understand is everybody else has people
outside everybody and that goes on to at
least 12.
okay
thank you chair well and that is the um
the application chair i know you want to
speak um here from environmental health
of course and um i would be interested
as well in the um conditions on it or
opening times on any of the other
licenses nearby
okay thank you so
what you're clearly saying is that the
three other bars in that terrace all
have a later license to to 12 o'clock
and they all they all have
residential properties next to them
above them
right and
just could you confirm whether you've
had any complaints about any noise
we haven't no and then no no there's
noise environmental health haven't
contacted about anything either
okay i'll just ask if any anybody any of
the other
any of the other characters on the panel
have any questions or any offices
ah no to me thank you dave no yes sir
can i just ask a question yes
has there been any
one for the licensing officer as well
actually has there been any uh
complaints any issues from
to the any of the other bars
in the
neighboring bars
as a result of the extra licensing house
they've got
i um
i i can i'm not aware of any um
uh
ongoing complaints concerning
any of the premises that have been
mentioned
just uh perhaps just just just some
information i think that was mentioned
about the um
the uh the com club they do have um
a a a first floor dining and drinking
area at the back which is which is very
close to a bedroom
but that has got um
[Music]
quite that i think that has a planning
condition that
that means it's not to be used past
past 9 p.m
to protect the residents that live
as a
habitable room close by to the to the to
the cut to the current club so if that
has been used
outside those hours that is going
against something that was agreed but
that's very
licensing but by by planning conditions
because of a particular situation
with being proximity to a
bedroom or living quarters yeah exactly
yeah
it is very very very very very close and
and it did take
it yeah it did get a lot of attention i
think about 2017 or 18 there is a
planning condition that restricts the
the times that it is used at the back is
there any proximity to this particular
bar at the back
does it have any
kind of uh
link we haven't got any seating out that
the seating is only out front
yeah but yeah okay thank you
there you go
okay is there any other questions for
the the applicant or the rep
representative
yeah
chair if it's possible just
uh question if that's if that's possible
uh i was just uh wondering if the
applicant can tell us how
um
how capacity is controlled
outside in the external external
drinking area
and just um
what
measures and mitigation are employed to
perhaps um to control noise from from
the external areas
we do have a dauben on friday and
saturday nights um we have no problem
with the dormant thing but we've been
let down quite a few times in the past
for the dorm and that's why we had this
discussion with the police because we
didn't want to be put in that situation
and we do have a doorman on friday and
saturday night so they they control the
outside area for us um anyone that
obviously too drunk or anything we asked
to leave anyway it's just a normal
licensing rules
um and if it's anyone being loud or
rowdy that's what they're going to do
for us that's their main role for us
is to manage outside
okay okay
okay well in that case
there's no further questions for the
applicant if i could ask you mr pollock
to
speak to your representation please
yeah um thank you chair members of the
licensing committee
my name is richard [ __ ] i'm team
leader in the environment and
environmental protection uh team as part
of the council's regulatory services
uh just just for your information as as
the applicants may be aware it was my
colleague nasreen ali miss nashville
environmental health officer
but only dealing with with this
application which is she's not available
this evening
and my application is is
my representation is based upon
the the application that
recommended that request the 1am
finish rather than the the midnight that
has has been mentioned
by um the applicant's representation
earlier on
um so my representation is made
based on the licensing objective for the
prevention of public nuisance in this
case in relation to noise
the external drink area of kennedy's
irish bar is directly overlooked by an
adjacent residential property
at 34 greenwood street
the first and second floor of this
adjacent
property has no extensive rooms which
face onto the external drinking area
including living rooms and bedrooms so
when we've considered this application
the environmental protection team have
uh considered the close proximity of
noise sensitive residential prop
premises to the application sites and we
feel it is required that appropriate
controls are put in place
as well as the relevant conditions
recommended to achieve the licensing
objective of the prevention of public
nuisance
noise from external drinking areas will
typically comprise of conversation
between patrons of the premises
and it would be reasonably expected
there'll be frequent incidents of raised
voices
shouting laughing arguing singing
throughout the evening
and in this particular case because of
the hours it would be into the night
time
experience within the environmental
protection team confirms that it does
not require a large number of people to
cause a disturbance
in the applicant homestead mentioned
potentially up to 40 40 people
who could be present rey's voices
shouting laughter are unpredictable
noise sources but when audible within a
residential property have the capacity
to disturb rest and sleep
such noises are very difficult to
mitigate and the impact of this type of
noise nuisance is often best controlled
by suitable hours of operation
the level of noise nuisance would be
expected to be highest during warmer
months when use of the area will be at
its highest but also when residents will
require windows open for ventilation
purposes
noise and disturbance from the external
drinking area being used as late as 1am
and fridays and saturdays will
inevitably disrupt the use and enjoyment
of the adjacent property
residents will most likely be subject to
regular instances of raised voices
shouting arguing
during the night time which will cause
significant disturbance
these comments are made
on the basis of the town centre location
of kennedy's but also
our understanding of the proximity of
residential properties
in view the information that's been
provided by um
the representation from the council's
environmental protection team i would
request that if members are minded to
grant the varied premises license should
it be
restricted
and as for the following request or
condition which is that use of the
external drinking areas the front of the
premises will not be permitted beyond 2
300 hours on any day
uh further to this uh
within miss ali's representation she's
also provided a response in relation to
to other parts of the variation
application but i understand parts have
been
withdrawn but as i understand we with no
objection to to points two and three of
the variation
and we would like uh recommend that
condition
11
is
is removed
and that
the following conditions on the current
license remain in place which are 16 17
18 20 and 21 but i don't believe that
they um that is um
that's been agreed with with with the
applicant
so um that's my representation if there
are
any any questions
okay thank you mr pollock can i just ask
you have you received any complaints
about noise from the the outside area
from from any of those establishments
not
not from from
not from kennedy's
um
and i don't i don't believe we've
received any relation to to any of the
uh joining premises
so uh no
so i mean i think i think everybody
understands about the proximity to
residential properties but it i mean
sort of how scientific is that has there
been a survey done of
which properties are inhabited
and the proximity well to kennedy's in
this instance
so
um
there has been studies done where you
look at noise levels from
from people
uh when they are so socializing without
with alcohol in involved
um but i think in this in this
particular case i think we look at the
proximity of of the windows and how
close they are
we rely on our experience and judgment
to understand that when there's people
outside and oh there's a fair number of
people outside and
and and voice voices are raised and and
then people enjoying a night out and
that that is that is part of it
it will be audible inside
properties particularly during the warm
months when windows are open and it
doesn't often need that that many people
to create a problem
okay thank you just ask if there's any
other questions
for the environmental health officer can
i just say something on that one um just
so
next we've got one property that's next
to us okay so next door but one above
them is one that's in close proximity
and there's a couple more down the road
that's above belgium bar and between
belgium bar and conclude and there's
some further down the street the other
way past riddles so there's in theory to
the other bars there's only one that's
impromptu limited to as compared to the
other bars
yeah i i understand these i think it's
that it's it is this there are
residential properties i think of 42 and
44 but 30 yes 30 for the the flag
oh sorry
is the key key respect yeah the 42 and
44 ones the ones above belgium bar and
that area there
which again is what we're saying is it's
we're no different to anybody else
really and it's just we're trying to
level the level and playing field really
with commercial finally commercially
viable and just being fair really
okay
jeff
hello yeah councillor thomas uh yeah mr
point do do we take a cumulative effect
of of noise so for example
as it may seem possible we are waiting
to find out what the licensing
conditions are for
con club belgium bar and even riddles
next door
to this bar do you take a cumulative
effect because i mean i have the opinion
that uh
obviously as noise gets louder and
louder you have to make um
make people aware of their
responsibilities in terms of residence
wherever there may be
but do you take accumulative effect of
noise so do you have a point where you
you make a decision that
it would be detrimental to residential
properties to have a another bar um
launching a later outdoor license for
example
yeah it is it is it is it is difficult
and and
like like you said i haven't got the the
external
um
times for the belgian bar and and
riddles on on greek greenwood street so
so so in in this particular case
was a 1
application so we we've judged that on
its on on its on its particular merits
in in this particular case but noise
from patrons is so
unpredictable depending on so so many
different different factors that that we
that we we we have to just take on a
site specific basis so so i think what
you're saying is that if you have the
similar number of people outside
uh it is difficult so that's why we are
looking more at time controls because we
understand that if they've got close
proximity of residential properties
to external drinking areas more than
likely it is going to be audible and we
understand that up to a certain time if
you live in a town centre that's that is
what you what you expect
but at some point
residents would have to have some
consideration to ensure
that
the disturbance is not excessive to them
so so conversely then if i could follow
up with that conversion if it turns out
i'm hoping we'll get the information
back
uh
this evening if it turns out that the
neighboring bars are licensed say for
example on a friday and saturday
and preceding a bank holiday
uh to 12 o'clock on those nights and yet
at 11 o'clock
on these on on normal sunday to monday
sorry sunday or thursday evenings would
that sort of withdraw your um
opposition due to the fact that
next door for example is riddles bar or
belgium bar which is approximately
30 yards up the road perhaps
uh have a later outdoor license with
that would that impact on on how you
uh in relation to noise
um made it made
a judgement call on a bar of a similar
size
requesting similar timings for outdoor
use
um well yeah of course that that that
was something we would we'd have to have
to cons have to have to consider i'm
not
my own my understanding is that
the
the i i i i wouldn't have thought they'd
be have external areas until till
midnight is my honest thought so i'll be
interested to hear the feedback i think
riddles i don't think they've got any
restriction i think theirs is
i'll later quickly jump in there and i
have i do have the information
um
sorry all three
don't have any restrictions to the
outdoor areas sorry
all three of those other premises do not
have uh restrictions to the outdoor
areas what's the latest licensing hour
then friday
friday and so well
i'm not 100 sure i can check that for
you though if you want to restrict them
to the outside areas okay all right
mr pollock i wonder if i could just try
and summarize here um because i think in
essence what you're saying is that
uh the 34 greenwood street and i
appreciate this is your colleagues
mata you've picked up you in essence
what you're saying is there is a
resident in 34 greenwood street who's
never complained about the outside area
being used until 11 pm
yet you believe that one hour
in the use of that area is going to
cause a public nuisance is that in in
essence what you're saying
well it was and i think as i said at the
start it was based on a one o'clock
finish we haven't we haven't had any
complaints but
i think as we've said the later you go
on the more likely you are to cause
a disturbance we haven't had any
complaints that that is absolutely
correct
um but yes our representation is on is
on the times that have been provided we
feel
uh could create disturbance for for the
residents
okay thank you
sure can i come in thank you good yes
yeah
has there been any uh
response from the uh to the application
from 34
uh has any objection raised
no
right and has it been notified in any
way to that
that particular application
are they cognition of it well there's
been blue noses up outside it's been in
the newspaper um that's the way it's
been notified i mean there were it's
um counselor you'll see the notices that
are in the application pack i uh
find it difficult to believe that
somebody would walk past
in such proximity to this place not know
that this application is being made
okay thank you
okay
if there's no further question that i'll
ask both parties to to summarize uh
starting with mr pollock as a
representator
um if you you've got two minutes if
you'd like to summarize the case for the
representative please
okay thank you thank you chad i think i
think just just just to just uh to go
over the points that i've that i've
raised the uh
the application that was
was made was to extend the east external
drinking area on fridays and saturdays
through until uh what one uh one am uh
the exile being here at kennedy's is
overlooked by residential property and
habitable rooms
noise from external uh drinking drinking
areas
is is extremely difficult to control and
doesn't take
significant numbers of people to cause
disturbance particularly we are um going
into into the night time
so so so we we we feel that uh to
protect the residential properties
that the use dixon don't drink carrots
the front of the premises should not be
permitted beyond 2 300 hours
thank you chair
okay thank you um
could everybody all right just i didn't
off miss screen froze for a minute but
it seems to be back on now
okay and mr williams do you want to
summarize the case for the
please yes please child just real
specifically with this external area
point so
um i think we understand what
environmental health is saying we pulled
the application until one o'clock we
negotiated
and said we would be happy to accept at
the terminal hour of midnight on the um
external area on friday saturdays and on
those
special days i think that's where we
reach the uh the log jam with
environmental health and unfortunately
that meant that we would have to go to a
hearing specifically to
um address that point now i understand
that the position mr pollitt's in and
having made this representation based on
the one o'clock but i do think that
having reduced the hour the terminal
hour for the use of the external area to
to midnight does change things you've
heard very clearly there is a resident
next door that resident since this uh
bar's been open how long have you been
open for rebecca nearly a year
nearly a year and that resident whilst
this bar's been open
um
and bearing in mind that's been through
summer time as well and during covert
when the use of the external area would
be
um
and
considerably more than um than at other
times
um there'll be no objections to 2300 for
the use of the external area and i don't
see why that position should change uh
it's as you've heard it's a supervised
area there's a doorman there on the busy
times supervising it and maintaining
control it's not the sort of place where
people are screaming and shouting
outside and i do think there should be
consistency with the other premises on
greenwood street of course the
consideration is here is is this going
to
undermine the licensing objectives i.e
is there going to be a public nuisance
by allowing this now
disturbance
and nuisance are two completely
different things so if say for example
somebody at midnight was uh disturbed by
a scream wherever it comes from where it
emanates from uh kennedy's or the con
club
that's not necessarily a public nuisance
and people have to be
uh accepting the fact that they are
living in a vibrant town centre near to
the market with the other bars and the
benefits that go with that and i'm not
saying that they are to have their lives
blighted by having people out in the
street but that part of greenwood street
is actually becoming more and more of an
extended outdoor vibrant space to have a
drink in the summer and into the early
evening and i don't see why this
application should lead to public
nuisance
and therefore i would urge you to
grant it
okay thank you
um right
uh thank gonna thank everybody for the
contributions
we're now going to
retire into the breakout room to
discuss the application and make our
decision and uh
we'll be back in a few minutes to uh to
deliver that decision
okay thanks for now everyone
enough to leave you can
put it into the breakout room please